my name is my three ramen and I'm from
Bangalore in India my host University
was the ludwig maximilian university in
munich i worked in the lab of Professor
uhlrich artal at the Max Planck
Institute of biochemistry the benefit to
Mike rewards that she learned how
science works on a day-to-day basis my
research project in particular focused
on cellular models of Huntington's
disease which is a neurodegenerative
disorder that is extremely debilitating
it causes a progressive loss in memory
and muscle coordination and it currently
has no cure when they leave our lab I
would really hope that they were able to
get a glimpse of the excitement that
science can provide growing up I didn't
really know where to call home i was
born in India but then we moved to
Malaysia and then China Singapore and
Vietnam and now I'm studying in London
each time we moved I was thrown into a
new school and you said of people and a
new culture so everything constantly
felt like it was changing but the good
thing about moving around so much is
that you begin to find the things that
you want to make consistent in your life
for me one of those things was my
scientific education I always felt a
sense of comfort in knowing that
scientific knowledge is the same no
matter where you go
so actually the amgen scholars program
was the first time that I was able to
contribute to a substantial research
project really grateful to be a part of
something that could potentially lay the
groundwork for a cure especially for
something as debilitating as
Huntington's disease my mentor you Jin
and I grew tremendously clothes and my
three came to the lab and she asked me
what her project would be my approach
was to try to get her to tell me what
the most interesting part of the project
was to her and she really encouraged me
to ask lots of questions I think the
amgen scholars program is really great
different people are successful in
taking different paths it's all about
finding what's right for you and a good
mentor can help you make kind of
informed decisions at every step of the
way the quickest way to improve yourself
as a scientist is to just throw yourself
into research that interest you and see
if you have the aptitude for it and if
you enjoy it I would definitely
recommend the Amgen Scholars Program
it's life-changing
you